la distancia que recorre un objeto es
directamente proporcional al tiempo que
viaja déjame llamarle a esta distancia
de iu a este tiempo le vamos a poner t
entonces lo que nos están diciendo es
que existe una constante acá de tal
forma que ve la distancia es igual acá
esa constante multiplicada por t muy
bien esto es que desea directamente
proporcional a t y luego nos dicen si un
asteroide recorre tres mil kilómetros en
seis horas cual es la constante de
variación
bueno aquí le pusieron constante de
variación yo le digo la constante de
proporcionalidad vale bueno entonces
vamos a meter los datos que nos dan a
esta igualdad nos dicen que la distancia
que recorrió fue 3000 kilómetros 3.000
kilómetros entonces tres mil kilómetros
es igual a esa constante cada x el
tiempo en el cual lo recorrió o sea por
seis horas
y lo que nos piden es determinar qué es
decir necesitamos despejar la de esta
ecuación y para hacer esto basta dividir
entre seis horas de ambos lados aquí
dividimos entre seis horas de este lado
dividimos entre seis horas seis horas y
por lo tanto haber aquí esto se cancela
de este lado tres mil entre seis es 500
500 y las unidades nos quedan kilómetros
por hora bueno déjame reescribir esto
por acá a la derecha entonces acá la
constante de proporcionalidad es igual a
500 500 kilómetros por hora
kilómetros por hora y entonces listo ya
tenemos la constante de proporcionalidad
o bien como le dicen aquí en el problema
la constante de variación